gilina 2.0 is shaping up to be more
serious than ever before norm on e and
colleagues new collab and what it means
for the future of fifth harmony plus the
most swill worthy TV first kisses well
happy Valentine's Day my babies
everyone tired of all the sappy posts
yet I hope not because I Instagram a
pizza AKA my one true love
meanwhile one couple also going strong
Selena Gomez and Justin Bieber no public
display of affection so far today from
Jelena in fact they may be spending
v-day apart Gomez is in New York for
Fashion Week where she ditched the short
blonde ooh and went long and brunette
with bangs Selena's first post-rehab
event with the press coaches 2018 fault
runway show makes sense she is the face
of the brand after all now around the
same time Justin was 3,000 miles away
but we're told they're in a good place
for now quote Justin Bieber and Selena
Gomez picked up right where they left
off after her short stint at the
Wellness retreat earlier this month
Selena completed a 2-week treatment for
depression and anxiety in New York our
source says justin has been very
supportive of his girlfriend putting her
health first and he was one of the first
people Selena saw after rehab we've
learned that superstar couple is
approaching the relationship differently
this time around they both grown
individually and have different
priorities our source says quote Justin
isn't interested in partying and Selena
is much more confident and isn't afraid
to put her needs ahead of anyone else's
I think it's because you're if you're in
my opinion I feel like if you're still
there's not really a lot of change and
I'm I'm constantly somebody that likes
to grow and feel like alright what could
I be better what could I do better at
where where could my confidence be
stronger and
and then I'm 25 so I feel like I'm gonna
change a lot and enjoy that you know a
lot of that growing seems to be in
private Selina has been pretty silent on
social media recently and our source
adds the singer is preparing to work on
you music alright now speaking of new
music Khalid and normanni just dropped a
collab just in time for Valentine's Day
it's not even new music Friday yet but I
just had to share their new song
together called love lies
[Music]
show me
[Music]
the song is off the soundtrack for love
Simon due out next month but what does
noir Monty's latest solo endeavor mean
for fifth harmony well fear not
Harmonizers normanni tells beats 1 radio
host zain lo they are rock solid we've
literally been through any and
everything you could possibly imagine
like good and bad so we're resilient I
would really call this resilient and
everything that we've been through I
feel like literally it's us against the
world and that's together and apart like
we'll always have some place to call
home which is fit harmony well how's
this for harmony it is v-day and I think
there is one thing we can all agree on
our real life first kisses are nothing
like on TV there's nothing quite like
watching your favorite couples finally
lock lips and we at et online came up
with a list of the most swim worthy TV
smooches we saw plenty of kisses during
Glee's 60s and run but none made us more
giddy than when Blaine surprised Kurt
with this okay but these two office
mates spent two seasons of flirting
before Jim went all in with his casino
night confessions of love he played his
cards right and won a sweet first kiss
with Pam listen Jim but does it get any
better than this before these two were
on a break Ross and Rachel kicked off
their on-again off-again relationship
with this perfect rainy night kiss and
Central Perk on friends
he's her Lobster I love love even that
fake love on TV are you guys to see a
full list of the best first TV kisses
head over to ET online.com slash daily
Deni
alright guys whether you're in love
celebrating with some pals or flying
solo this year which by the way
self-love is a thing to go enjoy your
Valentine's Day you little lovebirds and
I'll see you tomorrow